how do I get sin is the Institute of
arson ideas unique festival combining
days full of talks and debates in
philosophy politics arts and science
with evenings full of music and dance
get your tickets for the world's largest
musical philosophy first of all how that
I guess in dog do we think that sex
robots might reinforce dangerous ideas
about sex or sexuality and maybe I can
ask you that sure well I I do I have to
say I mean I this is another serious
concern which I think I'm sure I share
probably with the other panelists but
but you know the essentially the
objectification of of women through as
Kate said that you know hyper sexualized
robots in a sense is reinforcing it's
taking what I regard as one of the great
evils of humanity which is sexism and in
particular misogyny I want to highlight
misogyny as a singular evil if you like
in the world and you know what we're
doing is reinforcing it and and also
profoundly depressingly we're
transferring at an evil from the real
world if you like into the the
artificial world III would probably
disagree with you on many points simply
having worked in sex work myself that
many of the assumed evils are evils of
perception by people who are not
involved in it in any way I certainly
have the problem of being objectified as
almost robotic by people who are in
favor of eliminating sex work in sex
workers altogether so I already
experienced people telling me that my
existence is evil and not perceiving me
as a rounded human being when the
experience of so many people within sex
work is that you know as you were saying
before with the guys with the Real Dolls
I mean this is only if we're going to be
nation it's not entirely for everybody
they do treat them with a bit more
respect than we do as viewers looking at
that situation and this is certainly
true of the sex workers experience well
people are uninvolved with it project
the
basically their aesthetic taste on to
absolutely everybody within it these are
humans with Felician within that that
said and I just want to kind of throw
the hand grenade into if we did have
humanoid sex robots what would be the
problem of say having child sex dolls
child sex robots okay so I was coming
into I agree in some ways because I'm a
pro-sex feminist so I do see a problem
with the sexism in in terms of reductive
stereotypes that are not you know we see
this in lots of other things it's not
just sex robots it's music videos it's
whatever we I realize somebody's also a
Fantasyland and there are things like
there's a lot of talk about well sexual
violence against a robot translate into
real-world violence well first of all
there's there's been stories in the
press about people being violent towards
a sex robot it's completely looked into
it and it's one find it but we we've
seen the same arguments about computer
games we've seen the same arguments
about online porn
there has been no correlation between
the the access the sheer a huge access I
think we were talking us as 81 million
users a day or Finn was guessing any 1
million users a day on pornhub there has
not been a corresponding rise in sexual
violence no there are other influences
coming from the porn but not that sexual
violence korok correlation same with
videogames we don't have the evidence
without we don't this is no evidence
base here now when it comes to child sex
robots I think this is a more
problematic area in the UK last year
there were something like 123 arrests of
people importing childlike sex dolls
it's not illegal to own them in this
country it's illegal to import them but
it's it is a legal session of indecent
images of children and also to create
computer-generated versions of those
that's also illegal and it's not really
a stretch to see that being extended at
some point to cut to cover the dolls and
the childlike sex robots and the reason
I'm because I'm not I don't think that
we should be banning I don't really
should think we've been planning
anything because that's a slippery slope
and prohibition doesn't work I don't
think we should be worried about the
Alec versions of the dolls it's the
child ones because it reflects the a
social set up where it is illegal in
real life
obviously there's a social taboo I mean
when we talk about things being illegal
kind of where where the line is is a
little bit arbitrary we're talking about
law and ethics really has a relationship
with law but it's not one-to-one and
onto so when we talk about something
like that would there then be a problem
with other things that are perhaps
unethical and and non-consenting such as
a sex doll dog yeah this is a thing yeah
it needs to be weighed up on the damage
of what's going to happen in real life I
don't have the evidence for it all but I
mean I think the the the University of
Montreal has done a study in University
of Quebec has on the study on the use of
creating virtual reality situations
where sex offenders have seen you know
the images of children for example in
situations that would arise and they've
used it to see whether or not they've
responded to treatment and that could be
something that that these are use for
I've spoken to both people who said yes
you could use the trial sex tools as a
proxy as a way of handling fantasy for
pedophiles who and many PETA files never
offend there's a difference between
child molester pedophile child molesters
someone who has committed a crime of
that nature against children but may not
fundamentally be attracted to children
but they've committed a crime whereas
some pedophiles will never act on that
it may be that those sex robots are
something for them
then again I've talked to other
psychologists who work with sex
offenders and work with pedophiles
who've said please never offer this
opportunity it is just an escalation we
just don't have evidence either way get
your tickets for the world's largest
music and philosophy festival how the
light gets in org